[Music]
hi mystery recap dear today i am going
to explain the fifth and sixth episodes
of the south korean survival drama squid
game called a fair world and ganbu
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
in the previous episode gi yoon's team
was about to lose the game of tug of war
so sang wu thought of a last minute plan
he asked everyone to loosen their grip
on the rope for a few seconds so their
opponents would fall down as they do gi
yoon who is at the front almost falls
off the bridge but the plan works and
their opponents trip and fall losing
their hold on the rope
the team uses this opportunity to pull
the rope harder than ever and finally
wins the game they lie on the ground in
exhaustion feeling the adrenaline rush
in their bodies while returning back to
their room the girl who cybiac had
recruited ji yong makes fun of a team
member who happens to be a priest they
return to the room to see dioxu's team
talking to each other migno stares at
the man subtly telling him she doesn't
need him anymore the group then sits
together while talking migno tries to
charm everyone so they will favor her
she also belittles ali for being a
foreigner and asks to see his passport
as they talk it is announced that the
lights will be off in some minutes they
know people might start killing at night
so the group plans to make a barricade
and stay awake in pairs to keep watch
as they try to build a safe zone using
the bunk beds dioxu approaches gi yoon
and makes fun of him for thinking the
beds can stop them from being killed
giun on the other hand warns him of his
own team members he thinks since deoxy
has been ordering them around he might
be their first target his words get into
deoxy's head so he tells his team that
they won't be killing tonight enom
offers to be the first one to keep watch
saying that old people do not need to
sleep but the kind man is told to shut
up by a new member because they cannot
keep an old man as a guard
soon the lights go out and seng wu and
ali stay awake to guard the others ali
thanks sengwu for saving his life today
and hands him a cob of corn that he had
saved for him sang wu breaks it in half
and the two enjoy the corn together
while talking he asks ali to call him
hyung which means big brother in korean
they share stories about how they ended
up in the game after a while sang wu
wakes gi yoon to swap the duties dioxu
also can't seem to fall asleep for fear
of being killed himself
meanwhile the police officer jun ho is
taken to the room where some staff
secretly harvest the dead player's
organs he finds out that the man he
killed on the ship was also involved in
the secret program the doctor is there
too performing the procedures he gets
into an argument with the staff for
being slow back in the room enom joins
gi yoon to keep watch gi yoon tells him
how he was not paid for 10 years worth
of work because the car company he
worked at was at a loss enam sympathizes
with him and starts crying all of a
sudden giun tries to calm him and
realizes that the old man has a fever he
makes him lay down but doesn't have
water to help reduce his fever sybioc
offers him some and the two put enom to
sleep it is now their turn to keep watch
meanwhile the doctor finishes harvesting
the organs and hands them to june ho and
another staff member who are supposed to
dive underwater and give them to the
buyers in the sea after they leave he
asks the others about tomorrow's game
but it turns out even they do not know
what it will be the doctor freaks out
saying that he will be killed if they do
not tell him he holds one of them
hostage and asks the other staff to
figure out about the game they get into
a fight leading the doctor to run out to
the hallways but he gets lost in the
maze and doesn't know how to return a
staff member follows him to the
playground where the game honeycomb was
played he asks the doctor to calm down
because if they are caught all of them
will be killed the doctor asks him to
show his face so that he can trust him
the two are talking when suddenly the
overseer of the facility shoots the
staff member he then says that he
doesn't care what the staff does with
the dead bodies but they aren't allowed
to tell the players about the games that
ruins the main essence of the facility
which is equality he then kills the man
while the other staff shoots the doctor
dead
at the same time june ho and a staff
member go down through an emergency exit
which the man claims are for the vips
june ho vagley asks him about the vips
but the man reveals no one knows who
they are he becomes suspicious of june
ho for inquiring so much and asks him to
open his mask the man finds out june ho
is a different person but before he can
react junho points his gun at him he
inquires about his brother but the man
doesn't know anything about him but he
tells him about the player's information
file in their overseer's room where he
can find his brother's information a
secret stairway that leads him to the
overseer's room lies nearby juno shoots
the man dead and enters the overseer's
room
after he is gone the overseer and the
staff come downstairs to see the man who
was killed by june ho the overseer digs
the bullet out of his head and realizes
it belongs to a policeman the staffer
ordered to find the man as soon as
possible an alarm begins blaring waking
the players up they are quickly made to
line up in the middle by the staff enam
refuses to get up and it turns out he
had peed himself at night meanwhile june
ho is in the overseers room where he
finds the files of every single person
who has ever participated in the game he
figures that the games have been played
for many years now the players are then
made to stand in lines in the middle of
the room gi yoon helps enam by tying his
jacket around the old man's waist so he
won't be embarrassed after that the
players are then taken outside through
the halls where everyone is horrified to
see the dead bodies of the doctor and
the staff who helped him hung from the
ceiling an announcement is made saying
that this will happen to anyone who
breaks the rules for their own benefit
in the meantime june ho is still in the
overseer's office taking pictures of the
documents he thinks are important he is
searching for his brother's file when he
hears a phone ringing outside the
overseer comes into the room and picks
it up he talks to a foreign man in
english about a minor disturbance that
happened between the staff and assures
the person on the other end everything
will be good when the vips arrive after
the overseer leaves june ho picks up the
phone and tries to call the number back
but to no avail
in the meantime the players are taken to
an empty white room where they will have
to separate into groups of two gee
yoon's team needs to separate as well
they look at each other in confusion
migno tries to sweet talk giun to team
up with her when he doesn't speak she
makes her way to seng-wu who also
declines her offer sang-wu asks ali to
be his teammate and the two look at giun
to see if he objects giun asks them to
go ahead and starts looking for a
teammate himself enom makes his way
towards him but gi yoon knows he cannot
win with an old man as his partner so he
apologizes to him enom simply gives him
his jacket saying that the others might
look down upon him if he doesn't have
one giun feels bad for the man but goes
looking for a member anyway sybiac and
ji yong join hands as well a man asks gi
yoon to be his teammate he reveals that
since the doctor is dead it leaves an
odd number of players so the one with no
partner will probably be killed gi yoon
looks at enom sitting alone in a corner
and feels awful for abandoning him so he
asks the old man to be his partner in
the end the one person who doesn't have
a partner is migno she makes a fuss
about them not being able to win without
her as the players make their way to
play the game she is taken away by the
guards the players are then brought to a
mock neighborhood with several houses
and streets enom and giun talk about the
alleyways looking like their childhood
homes while ali and seng wu promise each
other that they will win the money
together for their families however all
of their plans fail when it is announced
that the pairs will be going against
each other they are given 10 marbles
each and told to play any game they want
to with them most of them choose either
a game where you should throw the
marbles into a pit or a game in which
one guesses how many marbles the other
person has they are given 30 minutes to
complete the game gun is shocked but
enom seems to be looking at the marbles
in fascination he has completely
forgotten what he was here for as the
game begins everyone starts playing but
enom goes around the blocks looking for
his house
gi yoon tries to stop him but he doesn't
want to play the game saying that it is
childish at last gi yoon slams the old
man to the wall in frustration knowing
that both of them will die if they do
not play enom trembles in fear and
accepts at the same time ali and seng wu
who treat each other like brothers have
to go against each other now all he
doesn't want to play the game but
sang-wu insists that they do or else
both of them will lose ali doesn't even
know how to play it so seng-wu teaches
him one of them will have to keep a
certain number of marbles hidden in a
fist the other will guess if the number
of marbles in their fist is odd or even
if the guess is correct all the marbles
the person is holding will go to the
person who made the correct guess the
two start playing and ali makes the
right guess at first taking two of
sengwu's marbles eventually ali wins all
of sengwu's marbles except for one when
people start dying sang wu claims that
he has a way they can both win an
innocent ali who doesn't want to be the
reason senghwoo dies listens to his plan
sengwu claims that at the end of the
game people are not going to agree on a
winner because they will nitpick the
rules the staff will then have only one
way to continue that is to make one team
go against another so they make a deal
to go around the playing zone looking
for the players who are older so they
can go against them at the end ali still
doesn't understand sengwu's plan but
agrees to do whatever he wants because
he trusts him sangwoo also makes him
wear his marble bag on his neck so no
one can snatch it meanwhile ji yong and
sabiak sit together not knowing what to
do sabiak being from north korea doesn't
know any marble games so ji yong offers
to teach her but both girls do not want
to play for 30 minutes so they decide to
just talk for most of the time and bet
all of their marbles on one game at the
end sybiak who normally doesn't like to
speak much reveals that her father died
while trying to cross the border and her
mother was caught by the chinese police
and sent back to north korea she wants
to buy a house and bring her mother back
after she wins the money ji young laughs
saying that she could do a lot more than
that with the money sybiak innocently
claims she wants to visit jeju island to
which ji yang offers to go together they
realize that it cannot happen because
one of them will die today jiong then
reveals that she killed her abusive
father and went to prison for it she has
no motive to live even if she wins the
money in the meantime enom and giun
start the game and inaum wins five of
giun's marbles in just the first round
as they go on gi yoon is left with only
one marble he nervously guesses odd for
the number of marbles inside enom's fist
only to discover it is even ge yoon
loses the game however enom forgets what
giun predicted allowing him to change
his answer starting that round gi um
uses enom's dementia to win every round
at last enom only has one marble left
but he starts looking for his house
again instead of playing similarly dioxu
also wins the game against one of his
minions when his marble accidentally
knocks diaxious into the pit ji yong and
sabiak decide to throw one marble at the
wall and the one who throws the closest
will win sybiak goes first and does
pretty well but when it is jiong's turn
she drops the marble on the ground
lazily making cybiak win
cybiac corners her and asks her to go
again because it isn't fair however ji
yong claims that she has nothing to live
for unlike her they say their last
goodbyes before a staff member shoots ji
yong dead
ali on the other hand goes looking for
sang-woo because only a few minutes of
the game are left but when he checks his
bag of marbles he realizes that his
brother-like friend has betrayed him
sang wu has exchanged all these marbles
with pebbles ali sheds one last tear
still in disbelief before a guard shoots
him dead
now only enom and giun are left they
have to play one last game for giun to
win but enam suggests they bet all of
their marbles on one last round gi yoon
is enraged claiming that this isn't fair
to giun's surprise enom reveals that he
knows ge yoon has been cheating him the
old man had faked having dementia to
make gi yoon win at last enom happily
hands his last marble to giun and thanks
him for playing with him gi yoon hugs
his friend for the last time and walks
out of the house sobbing the episode
ends as a gunshot startles him
indicating that enom has been killed
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching